[Música]
economía en directo América de Francia
24 segundo bloque de nuestra mañana de
miércoles Daniela Blandón vamos a hablar
de la reserva Federal que se espera un
aumento en las tasas de interés la
reserva Federal de Estados Unidos por
supuesto Hola Raúl Pues no hay mucho que
decir porque todo el mercado está a la
expectativa ya dan por descontado que el
Banco Central de Estados Unidos
anunciará hoy su sexto incremento
consecutivo para ponerle freno a la
inflación esto de las tasas de interés y
con las consecuencias que eso tiene para
la economía Como por ejemplo el
fortalecimiento del dólar si las
previsiones se cumplen la tasa de
interés oficial de la mayor Economía del
mundo pasaría a situarse en un Rango de
entre 3,75% y el 4%, un nivel no visto
desde 2007 y para darle una idea el año
pasado estaban entre 0 y 0 25% bueno y
antes de este anuncio echamos un vistazo
cómo están los mercados
a la baja y la cautela se tomó las
bolsas del mundo pues
el mercado está muy expectante sobre
esta decisión en Europa las acciones
están también a la baja con los
inversionistas preguntándose si este
alza de tasas que podría ocurrir hoy
también va a ocurrir en diciembre
próximo las acciones asiáticas cerraron
ligeramente al alzas impulsadas por esto
Pero además por la especulación de que
el gobierno podría estar preparándose
para relajar gradualmente las estrictas
restricciones de Kobe 19 a propósito de
la bolsa Raúl le tengo una noticia
bursátil Y es que la multinacional
Walmart y las farmacias CVS y Walgreens
de Estados Unidos acordaron pagar
conjuntamente
13.800 millones de dólares para resolver
miles de demandas de quienes las acusan
de darle mal manejo a la venta de
analgésicos opioides en más de 3.300
demandas se les acusa de minimizar sus
riesgos lo que derivó en centenares de
miles de muertes desde la década del 90
Cuando comenzó esta epidemia Bueno nos
venimos a nuestra región Dani porque en
Argentina van a investigar si hay
empresa que especularon con los precios
el secretario de comercio de ese país
Matías a Raúl tombolini firmó una
resolución en la que insta a la Comisión
Nacional de defensa de la competencia a
iniciar investigaciones por presuntas
prácticas anticompetitivas concretamente
el objetivo es descubrir si las empresas
vinculadas con la producción y
comercialización de bienes de consumo
masivo que hayan aumentado sus precios
durante todo este año lo hicieron como
resultado de un abuso de su posición
dominante en el mercado lo que las
enfrentaría a sanciones en lo que va
corrido del año la inflación de
Argentina acumula un 66%, pero si
comparamos los precios de hoy frente a
los de hace un año el incremento desde
el 83% en general 83% y más
multinacionales se rebelaron sus datos o
sus estados financieros Comencemos por
Sony que subió sus ingresos en 16% sus
ganancias en 24%. además anunció que se
preparó para la temporada de fin de año
con más 6,5 millones de unidades
producidas de PlayStation 5 en el
trimestre vendió los mismos 3 millones
3,3 millones de unidades que el año
pasado a medida que el negocio se está
desvaneciendo después del impulso que
tuvieron los consumidores atrapados en
casa en la pandemia Uber casi duplicó
sus ingresos frente al mismo trimestre
del año pasado Aunque registró pérdidas
netas porque realizó millonarias
inversiones de capital con la reapertura
de las ciudades y el auge del turismo
los consumidores están gastando más en
viajes que crecieron 14% en este
trimestre cerramos con pfizer que
aumentó sus ganancias en 6% más de 8.000
millones de dólares Aunque su
facturación se redujo un 6% Y es que las
ventas de la vacuna contra el 19 han
caído drásticamente aunque se están
compensando con otros productos y le
tengo bonus airbnb reporta una ganancia
récord de 1.200 millones de dólares para
el tercer trimestre a medida que están
aumentando esta reservas y tarifas
diarias promedio Aunque decepcionó bueno
el arete se cayó porque está tambaleando
esa arete porque él sabe que usted no va
a responder lo que yo le pregunté antes
si era que si pagaría usted por la copia
de la primera Constitución de Estados
Unidos Ya sé que me toca esperar el
arete ya me está dando la razón Jaja No
yo digo es que lo voy a pensar de aquí
al 13 de diciembre tengo un mes y 13
días para pensarlo porque la famosa casa
de subastas sobre bies pondrá a
disposición de los oferentes una copia
impresa de la primera edición oficial de
la Constitución de Estados Unidos que
fue adoptada en Filadelfia en 1787 los
investigadores dicen que cuando el texto
se imprimió se hicieron unas 500 copias
de esas sobrevivieron 13 11 estar en
museos o colecciones institucionales y
dos están en manos privadas una fue
subastada hace un año por 43,2 millones
de dólares la otra es la que sacarán en
diciembre y que esperan vender por entre
20 y 30 millones de dólares dato de
cierre la Constitución apenas tiene
artículos Dani como siempre Muchísimas
gracias por toda la información
económica por supuesto mañana más con
los aretes bien puestos mañana puestos y
Y por supuesto las reacciones de los
mercados internacionales sobre la Fed
Gracias Dani como siempre por toda la
información nosotros volamos direcciones
sin escalas hasta París